[Music]
greetings developers and welcome to
serverless migration station
a mini series that's part of serverless
expeditions i'm wesley
your conductor on these short trips
joining me is martin who will help me
help you navigate the world of
modernizing your applications
and porter our little friend here who
will help you get from point a to point
b
thanks wes i'm happy to be here what are
these migrations and why should
developers be
interested i'm glad you asked martin
well our job is to help developers
modernize their apps
to take advantage of new features and
product upgrades to move to a more
modern release of their development
language
and generally keep their apps running
well to support theirs or their
customers needs
in each episode our friend porter here
takes us on a short excursion to the
next migration station
each ride attempts to take the mystery
out of common migrations that developers
undergo
when modernizing their apps ah i get it
we're helping developers take advantage
of the latest innovations from google
cloud
so which migrations are we focusing on
first west
glad you asked martin the first set of
migrations we're going to tackle is for
original python app engine users
since it's launched in 2008 as our first
cloud product
we've continued to innovate and open the
platform as well as introduce
new products i'm familiar with cloud
functions and cloud run are you saying
users can run their app engine code on
those platforms too
yes martin app engine users have options
you can do nothing at all and stay on
app engine you can
modernize to the next generation app
engine service you can break up larger
apps into microservices for cloud
functions
or you can containerize your app for
cloud run
using docker is another way to stay on
python 2 forever for all of you hardcore
folks
if you don't want to learn about docker
or containers you can still containerize
using build packs but
only python 3 is supported this series
will cover most of these but
starts with helping you move to
unbundled services
hmm i like that google cloud is
embracing openness
and helping make my apps more portable
uh but what's
wrong with uh having the legacy app
engine services anyway
well nothing at all martin but while
bundled services are convenient
app engine isn't as open as it can be
for example while web app 2 is a great
lightweight framework
moving to something more general like
flask allows your app to be more
portable
meaning you can run your apps outside of
app engine if desired
by the way if you don't use flask you
can use any whiskey compliant framework
that does its own routing
you can read more in the documentation
also
many of app engine's original services
have matured to becoming their own
standalone cloud products anyway and
it's really where
all the new features are going so
migrating lets users take advantage of
their continuing innovation
okay i understand the tech implications
uh but before the main content
what can you say about cost yes it's
true martin
migration does involve regular usage so
analyze varying costs you may incur like
data store access
pricing of the new standalone cloud
products free tier quotas and so on
in other words don't go into it blindly
and get surprised afterwards
for this reason the tiny sample app used
for the migrations
should not incur any charges but don't
let this data store usage go out of
control
watching videos is great but i want to
get my hands dirty
where should i go wes all right martin
well except for this video
each migration module has an associated
code lab
a self-paced free online tutorial to
give you that hands-on
users get both the starting and ending
code so you can reset back to the
beginning or compare your answers with
ours
while some migrations are strongly
recommended others are optional
it really depends on what makes sense
for your app if you need to start
migrating today
several codelabs have already been
published so there really is no reason
to wait
hey wes you mentioned you'll give us a
sample app to migrate
can you walk me through that starting
sample so i can get an idea of what to
expect
sure i'm happy too martin it's a simple
python 2
guestbook app using the web app 2
framework it records each page visit as
a data store entity
with the app engine ndb client library
we're going to dive into the code but
let's pause so you can clone the repo or
download the zip file
okay jump to the module zero code and
let's go to the computer to walk through
it now
let's start with the application file
main.py
the key imports bringing the webapp web
framework plus its templating system
and the app engine ndb library to access
datastore
next is a data model for each web page
visit we'll auto save the timestamp as
well as some visitor information and
that's it
fairly basic store visit creates the
entity with the visitor info we want to
save such as ip address and browser type
or user agent
then writes it with the timestamp to
datastore yes i know
x4 did four should be checked first and
so on but this is just a sample app so
grabbing the first thing that looks like
an ip address
rather than being thorough and correct
fetch visits queries for the most recent
visits which will be displayed with the
html template
for the primary handler the app only
supports http get which is why it's the
only implemented method
it registers a visit queries for the 10
most recent visits to display
including the one just recorded and then
passes the data to the template to
render
finally we have a routing table at the
bottom
i think all hello world app.yamls look
like this am i right
it's a python27 app where all routes go
to app in main.py
the last file is a basic index template
with some header info then a for loop
that displays the most recent visits
okay that's a quick walkthrough of the
baseline sample app you can find in the
module 0 repo folder
thanks for the tour of the sample app
west now i know what we're starting with
a basic python 2 app using the bundled
app engine services
by the way is this series for all app
engine users
glad you asked martin nope it's not for
everyone if you're a python 3
java 11 php7 or go112 or newer app
engine user you're already on the next
generation service
this first set of migration modules is
only for developers consultants
id decision makers integration
specialists or any technical
professional
interested in bridging the gap between
the first and second generation app
engine runtimes
thanks for helping users with these
modernization resources
uh do you have any roadmap on which
videos we'll see first
well thanks martin as as mentioned
earlier a starting set of codelabs is
already available so we'll be producing
videos for them first
but if you're curious here's a list of
all the code labs you can try now
there's no need to wait for a video if
you need to get started today thanks for
the heads up of what content to expect
are there any other resources that we
can share today
oh definitely martin in addition to the
migration modules
here are some links to the documentation
describing our long-term support of
these older runtimes and
more importantly that page links to the
migration guides for each of the legacy
runtimes
next is the repel for the samples in the
docs and finally yet another repo with
migration samples contributed by the
community
we look forward to having you join us
for the first leg on our migration
journey as well as on other serverless
expeditions
this is wesley chan on behalf of martin
and porter saying ciao for now but we'll
see you
at the next serverless migration station
[Music]
you